[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin einen schönen guten Abend
zusammen und Christian was für eine
Sensation bei der
Fußballweltmeisterschaft Marokko der
Favoriten schräg guten Abend ja dazu
gleich mehr hier ist der Überblick
[Musik]
kuptionsvorwürfe im EU-Parlament die
Vizepräsidentin Eva kayli soll von
Cutter Geld bekommen und sich im
Gegenzug für den Golf statt eingesetzt
haben
Schock in Dresden mitten in der
Innenstadt verschanzt sich ein Mann mit
Geiseln in einem Einkaufszentrum und
stirbt dann bei deren Befreiung
und Marokko schreibt Fußballgeschichte
bei der WM besiegt das Team Portugal und
schafft es als erstes afrikanisches Land
unter die besten 4
es wäre ein korruptionskandal wie in das
Europäische Parlament noch nie erlebt
hat im Fokus steht die festgenommene
Parlaments Vizepräsidentin die
griechische Sozialdemokratin Eva kaii
sie soll Geld sie soll gegen Geld so
muss man sagen höchstwahrscheinlich aus
Katha versucht haben Politik im Sinne
des golfstaates zu beeinflussen
Korruptionsvorwürfe die hat es im
EU-Parlament lange nicht gegeben zuletzt
vor zehn Jahren ein Grund ist das
eu-transparenz Register da müssen
Abgeordnete offenlegen mit welchen
Interessensvertretern also Unternehmen
Organisationen oder Einzelpersonen sie
sich treffen klar ist das System hat
Lücken und eine davon wurde im Fall
evakali offenbar erfolgreich
ein Parlament viele Meinungen so weit so
normal doch im November ließ eine Rede
aufhorchen
ein Land verbessern kann aber hier rufen
einige noch immer dazu auf Qatar zu
diskriminieren sie schikanieren sie und
beschuldigen jeden der mit ihnen spricht
der Korruption
Rednerin war Eva Kylie Sozialdemokratin
eine von 14 Vizepräsident innen sie
sprach in Katar mit dem Arbeitsminister
und ja korruption sei im Spiel sagen in
Belgien Staatsanwälte und nahmen Kylie
gestern fest Geld vom Golf habe dieser
Verein verteilt feine Adresse sauberer
Name weit im Unity gegen Straflosigkeit
doch beim Vorsitzenden dem ehemaligen
Europaabgeordneten panzeri fand die
Polizei über eine halbe Million Euro
Bargeld so belgische Medien gekaufte
reden das wäre so deutsche Abgeordnete
ein Skandal mit Ansage eigentlich ist es
Parlament ist die Europäische Kommission
schon ziemlich weit was Lobby
Transparenz angeht nur leider ist die
Einflussnahme durch Drittstaaten bisher
von allen Transparenzregeln ausgenommen
die Lücke könnte sich nun rächen
Menschen unwürdige Behandlung
ausländischer Arbeiter in Katar wollte
das Parlament verurteilen Kylie
inzwischen ausgeschlossen versuchte das
zu verhindern Sozialdemokraten müssen
sich erklären
das ist eine sehr ungewöhnliche Position
die sie da vertreten hat und auch nicht
eine die die Fraktion mit Mehrheit
vertreten hat und auch nicht die für die
wir abgestimmt haben der Zeigefinger den
es in Sachen Transparenz gern erhebt
berichtet sich nun gegen das Parlament
vertiefen wir das Thema mit Gunnar
Krüger in Brüssel wie groß ist die
Dimension dieses korruptionskandals
also alle Abgeordneten mit denen wir
heute gesprochen haben sagen das wäre
der größte Skandal den das
Europaparlament seit Jahrzehnten erlebt
hat und wie groß dieser Skandal ist das
hängt natürlich auch von den weiteren
Ermittlungen ab es sind ja neben Kylie
noch vier weitere Personen festgenommen
worden darunter auch Mitarbeiter von
Abgeordneten es sind einzelne Büros
versiegelt worden also es ist nicht
ausgeschlossen dass da noch mehr kommt
und noch mal zurück zur Vizepräsidentin
Kali hatte ihr mutmaßlicher Versuch
politischer Beeinflussung denn Erfolg
ja das wäre natürlich die andere
Dimension die diesen Skandal groß machen
würde wenn also der Versuch tatsächlich
auch zu Resultaten geführt hätte man
kann natürlich in den Protokoll
nachlesen diese diese Resolution um die
es da damals ging die wurde weder
verschärft noch abgemildert aber wir
wissen von mehreren Abgeordneten dass
sie direkt von Kylie angesprochen worden
sein dass sie eben mildere reden in
dieser Debatte halten sollen und so
bleibt schon allein durch diesen durch
diesen Versuch der Einflussnahme bleiben
schon gehörige Kratzer im lag beim
Parlament des Parlament steht ja in
diesem Konzert der Institutionen oft für
die reine leere während dem Rad der
Mitgliedstaaten und der Kommission so
ein bisschen die Realpolitik überlassen
wird aber wenn man jetzt so wie das
Parlament bei so vielen Themen wie Klima
oder Menschenrechte die lehrte so hoch
liegt ja da muss man sich nicht wundern
wenn man viel Kritik bekommt wenn man
sie heute mal reißt danke für die
Einschätzung nach Brüsseler Krüger da
wird also noch einiges kommen in diesem
Fall im Iran könnte sich die aktuelle
Protestbewegung durch die abschreckende
Wirkung von Todesurteilen abschwächen am
Donnerstag richtete das Regime einen
23-jährigen hin er soll ein Mitglied der
Sicherheitsbehörde verletzt haben
weitere Todesurteile will die
Staatsführung in den kommenden Tagen
vollstrecken aus Teheran berichtet Jörg
Brase für uns
wirdmar Hansa Draht der nächste sein der
sterben muss weil er an den
regierungskritischen Protesten Teilnahme
morgen könnte man Hansa Draht
hingerichtet werden weil er ein Mitglied
der Basic Milizen angegriffen von
MOTORRAD gestoßen und dieses angezündet
hatte
Gefährdung öffentlicher Sicherheit und
Ordnung Terrorismus und Krieg gegen Gott
lautete das Urteil neben sadrid warten
angeblich noch 20 andere Todeskandidaten
auf ihre Hinrichtung die Absicht hinter
diesen Urteilen ist denen die wir Fragen
klar doch sie wollen nicht vor der
Kamera reden wir dürfen nur ihre Stimmen
aufnehmen
das Regime tut das um uns Angst zu
machen sagt diese Frau es geht ihnen
nicht darum etwas zu verändern oder mit
dem Volk zusammenzuarbeiten sie werden
nicht nachgeben sie versuchen Angst und
Schrecken zu verbreiten
Oppositionsgruppen hatten für heute zu
schweigen Menschen aufgerufen bis zum
frühen Abend zeigten sich nur wenige
hundert auf den straßenkehrers schwer zu
sagen ob die Einschüchterung durch
Schnellverfahren und Hinrichtungen wirkt
ob die Zahl derer die sich auf die
Straße trauen tatsächlich singt steigen
aber werden vermutlich die Wut und die
Ablehnung die Sache Politik der
Regierung
Präsident sie bezeichnete die
Todesurteile als legitimer Antwort auf
die Ausschreitungen und von Seiten
konservativer Hardliner war die Drohung
zu hören das ist auch mit der Duldung
solcher Bilder bald vorbei sei sehr bald
schon so hieß es heute würden alle
Frauen im Land wieder Kopftuch tragen
zum Krieg in der Ukraine da sind im
russischen Militär nach eigenen Angaben
Vorstöße gelungen im Osten im Raum Donez
habe man ukrainische Soldaten aus ihren
Stellungen vertrieben ebenso weiter
nördlich bei Liman Millionen Menschen
leiden weiter unter Kälte und
Stromknappheit wegen der russischen
Angriff auf das ukrainische energie-netz
mittlerweile seien alle Wärme und
Wasserkraftwerke beschädigt so die
Regierung in Kiew
ein Schock mitten im vorweihnachtlichen
Dresden dort hatte ein Mann in einem
Einkaufszentrum zwei Menschen als
Geiseln genommen der 40-Jährige wurde
dann beim polizeizugriff getötet die
Geiseln blieben unverletzt der Täter
soll zuvor seine Mutter getötet haben
Einzelheiten jetzt von Franziska
wunderlich
es ist kurz nach 7 Uhr morgens als die
Polizei in den Dresdner Stadtteil
Prohlis gerufen wird sie finden eine
62-jährige getötet mutmaßlich vom
eigenen Sohn es folgen dramatische
Stunden in einer zunächst
unübersichtlichen Lage weil in dieser
Anrufe nacheinander einging Schüsse
gehört worden sein war das für uns eine
sogenannte lebensbedrohliche Einsatzlage
das hat sich dann letztlich hier als
stationiert dargestellt erst hatte der
40-Jährige versucht bei einem
Radiosender einzudringen gab dort
mehrere Schüsse ab danach flieht er in
die Innenstadt in einem Einkaufszentrum
nimmt er eine Frau und ein Kind als
Geiseln mit ihnen verschanzt er sich
über Stunden am Mittag erfolgt dann der
Zugriff durch Spezialeinsatzkräfte
die haben die Tür aufgebrochen haben
dann in bewaffneten Täter vor sich
gefunden und selbst auch die Schusswaffe
zum Einsatz gebracht und letztlich erlag
dann der Täter den Verletzungen die
Geiseln bleiben äußerlich unverletzt
werden aber weiter betreut um das
Erlebte zu verarbeiten nach ersten
Erkenntnissen soll der Geiselnehmer
psychisch krank gewesen sein
Corona im letzten Winter des hieß ja
hohe Infektionszahlen und strenge Regeln
ganz anders jetzt immer mehr
Beschränkungen werden aufgehoben nach
Sachsen-Anhalt braucht man jetzt auch in
Bayern in Bus und Bahn keine Maske mehr
das sei nicht mehr verhältnismäßig
andere Viruserkrankungen müssen
inzwischen häufiger behandelt werden als
Corona so die Begründung wie das ankommt
dazu Christoph Wiesel
Eigenverantwortung statt maskenpflicht
seit heute gilt das auch im Bus von
Sabri fitinshi das bei ihm jetzt wieder
viele Menschen ohne Maske mitfahren für
den Münchner geht das in Ordnung ich bin
selber geschützt und ich bin auch
genießen von vom Corona von daher machen
wir keine Gedanken Bayern lockert im
Nahverkehr ganz verschwunden sind die
Masken am Tag eins allerdings nicht auch
wegen Erkältungskrankheiten und so ist
heißt das passiert ja so viel ich bin
aus Augsburg runtergefahren und ich habe
es jetzt nicht getragen ich trage Maske
wenn halt viele Leute unterwegs sind
jetzt zum Hauptbahnhof aber wenn jetzt
sonst niemand da ist dann spare ich mir
auch nach und nach sollen Aufkleber und
Hinweisschilder von Bussen und Bahnen
entfernt werden die Münchner
Verkehrsgesellschaft begrüßt das Ende
der maskenpflicht für Sie fallen die oft
schwierigen Kontrollen Weg seit nur noch
im ÖPNV und in medizinischen
Einrichtungen die Maske verpflichtend
war hat die tragedisziplin bei den
Fahrgästen deutlich nachgelassen das
Verständnis hat auch gefehlt experten
sehen die Lockerungen dagegen
zwiespältig vor allem was den Schutz von
älteren und Menschen mit Vorerkrankungen
angeht
insbesondere Menschen die zur
vulnerablen Gruppe gehören aber im
Alltag auf den ÖPNV angewiesen sind
profitieren stark davon je mehr Leute
eine Maske tragen im dicht getränkten
ÖPNV auch deshalb dürfe das Ende der
maskenpflicht nicht als Freifahrtschein
verstanden werden eine Empfehlung zum
Masken tragen gilt in jedem Fall
auch bei den Nobelpreisen geht es nach
den corona-jahren wieder zurück zur
Normalität die Preisverleihung fand ja
wegen der Pandemie zweimal im kleinen
Rahmen statt heute aber wieder Gedränge
Gedränge im Stockholmer Konzerthaus auch
viele ausgezeichnete aus den vergangenen
Jahren waren dabei beim
Friedensnobelpreis in osloh wurden
Menschenrechtler aus Belarus der Ukraine
und Russland geehrt
am Ende brachte der Friedensnobelpreis
Menschen zusammen deren Länder Krieg
gegeneinander führen Alexandra madrifcuk
vom ukrainischen Zentrum für bürgerliche
Freiheiten wollte im Vorfeld des
Festaktes keine gemeinsamen Interviews
mit Jan raczynski geben der den Preis
für die inzwischen verbotene russische
memorialorganisation entgegennahmen
schließlich führe Russland Krieg gegen
die Ukraine
[Applaus]
ich erlaube mir die Menschen auf der
Welt um Solidarität zu bitten Sie müssen
keine Ukrainer sein um die Ukraine zu
unterstützen es reicht Menschlichkeit zu
haben gute prosto
die Auszeichnung nahmen sie aber
gemeinsam entgegen einer der Preisträger
konnte heute nicht in Oslo dabei sein
alles Pia jetzt gekämpft für Freiheit
und Menschenrechte in Belarus er sitzt
dort im Gefängnis den Friedensnobelpreis
nahm seine Frau entgegen
alles du bist nicht alleine sagte sie in
Richtung ihres Mannes wir stehen dir bei
das Nobelkomitee bezeichnete die beiden
Organisationen aus der Ukraine und
Russland und den belarussischen
Menschenrechtler als Champions des
Friedens
am späten Nachmittag erhielten auch die
Preisträger der Vorjahre ihre
nobelmedaillen darunter auch der
deutsche Chemiker Benjamin List und der
Astrophysiker Reinhard Genzel die späte
Ehrung wurde nötig da der Festakt in den
vergangenen zwei Jahren Corona bedingt
ausfallen musste
Zuspruch via Videogruß Bundespräsident
Steinmeier hat das Engagement der
Bundeswehr wenige Tage vor Weihnachten
im Ausland gewürdigt gemeinsam mit
seiner Frau bedankte er sich bei den
Soldaten in und Soldaten für ihren
Einsatz dieser sei für die eigene
Sicherheit so bündnisverteidigung und
zum Frieden in der Welt wichtig so
Steinmeier zur Zeit sind etwa 3.500
Bundeswehrsoldaten im Ausland
stationiert
in der EU sollen Batterien bald
umweltfreundlicher werden darauf haben
sich das Europaparlament und die
Mitgliedstaaten geeinigt bereits bei der
Gewinnung von Rohstoffen etwa Lithium
sollen ökologische und auch soziale
Standards gelten die Batterien sollen
länger halten und Akkus müssen in Handys
und Laptops so eingebaut sein dass nicht
nur Fachleute sie wechseln können die
neuen Regeln gelten allerdings wohl erst
in dreieinhalb Jahren
der heutige 10 dezember ist der Tag der
Menschenrechte meinungs- und
Pressefreiheit werden an vielen Orten
eingeschränkt warnt die Bundesregierung
und sieht aktuell Entwicklungen mit
Sorge Menschenrechtsverletzungen dürften
nicht straflos bleiben Unrecht aufzeigen
und aufarbeiten das will man in der
Gedenkstätte Zuchthaus Cottbus Kathrin
Lindner über einen Ort gegen das
Vergessen
mit 22 Jahren wird Peter Kolb hier
eingeliefert vor ihm liegt die Haft in
einem der größten politischen
Gefängnisse der DDR
als er 1981 nach Cottbus kommt teilen
sich politische Häftlinge und Kriminelle
die Zellen anfangs wird Peter Kolb mit
17 anderen Männern in einen Raum
gesperrt den letzten Glauben an sowas
wie wie Gerechtigkeit oder oder
ja dass ich andere Leute durchaus
staatlicherseits um mich kümmern
angemessen das habe ich ja völlig
verloren
Peter Kolb wächst in Radebeul bei
Dresden auf er ist 16 als die Familie
einen Ausreiseantrag stellt eine Zeit
der Repressalien beginnt unter anderem
darf er die höhere Schule nicht besuchen
sieben Jahre hält er das aus dann will
er in den besten fliehen und wird
gefasst das einstige Gefängnis ist heute
mal für Menschenrechte die hier
missachtet wurden
dass der Prozess warum man hier ein Haft
gewesen ist nicht fair gewesen ist dass
die Arbeitsbedingungen die
gesundheitsbedingungen wirklich
miserabel waren es gab Haft Zwangsarbeit
das ist sind Menschen hier zur Arbeit
gezwungen worden heute arbeitet Peter
Keup als Historiker an dem Ort wo ihnen
die DDR einsperrte und ihn die
Bundesrepublik für knapp 97.000 D-Mark
freikaufte man spürt am meisten was
Menschenrechte bedeuten wenn man sie
nicht in Anspruch nehmen kann deshalb
will dieser Ort kommende Generationen
vor Unrecht bewahren
die USA kämpfen gegen eine der größten
Umweltkatastrophen der letzten Jahre im
Bundesstaat Kansas sind offenbar mehr
als zwei Millionen Liter Öl aus einer
Pipeline ausgelaufen das Loch war vor
drei Tagen entdeckt worden soll
inzwischen geschlossen sein das Öl floss
unter anderem in einen Bach die Pipeline
transportiert von Kanada in die USA
ja jetzt zur Sensation bei der
Fußballweltmeisterschaft Marokko steht
im Halbfinale Christine das ist ja
Wahnsinn als erstes afrikanisches Team
überhaupt historisch die anderen sagen
märchenhaft ja wer hätte das gedacht
dass Marokko zum Favoriten Schreck
dieser Endrunde in katariert mit nur
einem Gegentor bisher ins Halbfinale
nach der Gruppenphase Spanien besiegt
und vorhin Portugal das 1:0 der
Marokkaner ein verdienter Triumph ein
Stück Fußballgeschichte der Glaube an
den erstmaligen Halbfinale einzuge eines
afrikanischen Teams wächst ins
Unermessliche als Ende sie in der 42
Minute zum 1:0 Marokko einkauft Portugal
Torwart Costa greift ins Leere
Bruno Fernande ich gelingt kurz vor der
Pause um ein Haar der Ausgleich für
Portugal kurz nach dem Wechsel kommt
Ronaldo und liefert dann auch die
Vorlage für die bis dahin beste
Ausgleichschance Portugals für Felix
marokkost Torwart Bono erst einmal
geschlagen im gesamten Turnier auch
Ronaldo bekommt noch seine Gelegenheit
Nachspielzeit wieder gibt es an Bruno
kein Vorbeikommen Marokkos Fans nach
Abpfiff im 7 Himmel Ronaldo in Tränen
aufgelöst die Außenseiter aus Marokko
haben tatsächlich das Halbfinale
erreicht
[Applaus]
und ebenfalls überaus emotional
Argentiniens Sieg über die Niederlande
Oranier hatte in der 11 Minute der
Nachspielzeit spektakulär den Ausgleich
zum 2:2 erzielt dann die Entscheidung im
Elfmeterschießen als lautaro Martinez
eiskalt die Chance nutzte und zum 4:3
verwandeltem
tja und im deutschen Fußball die nächste
Hiobsbotschaft Torwart Manuel Neuer
brach sich bei einer Skitour den rechten
Unterschenkel und wurde bereits operiert
die Saison ist dadurch für den Kapitän
des FC Bayern München beendet jetzt zum
Wintersport nach ihrem Sprintsieg wurde
Biathletin Denise Hermann Weg in der
Verfolgung von Hochfilzen fünfte beim
Erfolg der französischen Giulia Simon
auf dem Podest erneut die deutsche
Männerstaffel diesmal auf Platz 3 ein
starkes gott hat mit einem Nerven
starken Schlussläufer Benedikt doll so
schalt die Staffel es geht nach hinten
aber es geht auch wieder nach vorne
durch die Strafrunde des zweiten Läufers
Johannes kühnfeld Deutschland
zwischenzeitlich zurück auf Frank 10
Schlussläufer Benedikt doll übernimmt
als Wörter und kämpft an meinem letzten
Schießen mit Frankreich um Platz 3 der
32-Jährige nimmt sich die Zeit die er
braucht und sichert das Podest ab zum
zweiten Mal in diesem Winter gewinnen
die Norweger dahinter Schweden und
strahlender Dritter die deutsche Staffel
ja und auch unter den Top 3 das deutsche
mixteam beim Weltcup im Skispringen in
Titisee-Neustadt dem Quartett um Karl
Geiger Konstantin Schmid Katharina
Althaus und Selina Freitag fehlten am
Ende umgerechnet knapp 18 Meter zum Sieg
den sicherte sich Österreich vor
Norwegen morgen mehr Wintersport im ZDF
und gleich WM live hier bei uns wieder
England gegen Frankreich ich glaube ich
kann sagen ein Kracher und wir gucken
das beide absolute danke Christin
winterliche und trübe Aussichten kommen
gleich von Katja horneffer das heute
journal mit Marietta Slomka eben in der
Halbzeitpause der WM Party England gegen
Frankreich gegen 20:45 Uhr so viel von
uns schönen Dank schönen Abend und bis
morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend der Dezember hat kalt
begonnen und das kommt uns besonders so
vor weil die elf Monate davor besonders
warm waren ja das waren die wärmsten 11
ersten Monate eines Jahres seit Beginn
der regelmäßigen Wetteraufzeichnungen in
Deutschland 1881 und mit der Kälte kam
jetzt auch Schnee über die Alpen am
Alpenrand hat es heute schon geschneit
und schneit es auch in der Nacht noch
weiter etwas Schnee fällt auch im Osten
und an der Ostseeküste und bis Montag
abend welches sich dann hier über
Frankreich ein nächstes
Niederschlagsgebiet daran über Schnee
sinken die Temperaturen heute Nacht am
Alpenrand des minus acht Grad sonst sind
die Werte meistens in den leichten
bismäßigen Forsten es bleibt nach wie
vor glatt auf den Straßen denn es fällt
ja auch noch Schnee am alten Rand aber
auch Richtung Thüringen und Sachsen
sowie an der Ostsee manchmal ist der
Himmel auch klar und dann bildet sich
Nebel morgen am dritten Advent Block des
leicht weiter besonders aus Bayern in
Thüringen und in Sachsen und hier im
Erzgebirge kann es auch noch mal ein
bisschen länger schneiden das liegt dann
dort am Nordwind an gibt es einige
Schneeschauer sonst ist es häufig trüb
ab und zu zeigt sich aber auch die Sonne
bei Temperaturen meist im leichten
Dauerfrost und in den nächsten Tagen
geht es sehr winterlich weiter tschüss